good time of day to you much as friends
ah now you're surprised doing something
else at the start yeah this is good time
of day to you my chest friends this is
how grand master yelu lynskey usually
introduces himself and the videos and I
always wonder if this is really am a
normal way to you have to do it i mean
this is a good time of day two youths
and this is something that is common in
none in American English or British
English I don't know okay um while we
added it's a king's indian and it's some
pretty rare line with Bishop g5 my
opponent is called fonso fan fonso fan
from the UK oh he took on d6 ok I could
I could think about taking with the
bishop ok so we have a very young I
quite uncommon um form of the Kings
Indian here ok I don't mind to exchange
him quite a camera with an earlier with
an early Bishop g5 and I have initiated
regrouping here I always like this
roofing when I looked at the Kings
Indian in detail back when I regularly
played it like 15 years ago or so um I
had a really really thorough study of
our lines i mean really like hours and
hours and i forgot most of that but this
is one set up that actually now
remembered it sir ok let's preserve this
bishop i can always play at six um I
always found that thought it was the
most cute this regrouping ok nine f6 can
write a five if I can't a key for I've
got pressure against this maybe you can
take and play night each phone now that
I look at it hmm hmm maybe the good
thing about all this is I played it
rather quickly can I go nite age 52 f 4
here you know he doesn't he doesn't want
to play g3 that I'm show off g3 i can i
can just take and Bishop to g4 quite
this is some really annoying okay anyway
at night f6 i'm going to just invest a
couple of seconds he doesn't threaten to
take here Knight f6 threatens to take
bishop g6 does bishop f3 this is not
only Knight f6 he probably have he
probably placed 92 now and now I could
actually take this and then it probably
takes with the cenote a film I have to
have the perfect in bishop pal but i'm
not sure about them if this is so great
i mean okay he threatens on g6 wait
let's do that need to take here to keep
them f3 protected
and that's if I would not see for it's
not not the end of the world three is
sweetie weekend okay let's put a rock on
the CFO at the moment is not dominant on
the sea floor if he takes I can just
retake not much happening
yeah this Bishop only seven the Kings
Indian bishop hmm yeah maybe I should
have played Bishop g5 but then he could
take him they can take now this was okay
rook c8 was probably okay
hmm yeah this is surprising I can't give
a chicken see one
yeah okay let's do that now queen d 1
attending Bishop f3 winning it you
probably will see that but it's still a
good move i think what about 93 are they
still bishop no I can't go Queenie one
it's nothing special
hmm
yeah the Queen now it looks nice but it
doesn't do so much maybe this one rocks
you one year of course rooks you mom why
not use the CFO modest we fought along
very very easy and good move
whoopsie one wasn't working could just
take away so check him check just poking
around you but
i doesn't have a good coordination but
i'm down on time
white resigns really what is this suks
phone I don't really know what it is is
why I was white resigning I mean is
there I don't don't get it what is it
come saying yeah the comp actually says
I'm winning of course I'm just attacking
d5 sometimes sometimes you really really
ask yourself if you're awake or whatever
yeah yeah it is a win of course I just
take the five I completely forgot about
this pawn here he really has no way to
protect the five I never win d 5 it all
falls apart yeah I guarantee you if you
would have played I don't know what
moves I wouldn't I would have seen that
this is hanging I was just being blind
here yeah okay yeah I see some assemble
allowed all this activity I i don't
think that allow in quincy one was a
good idea here's something else I don't
know what exactly not c4 or something
can't allowing me into this position was
most probably a mistake to hear I'm very
very active check the idea ever really
winning this was getting downhill really
quickly yeah I completely forgot that
the five things I probably wouldn't have
taken it alright thanks for watching